gilbert blanc les clowns blancs j'ai la
terreur des clowns blancs ouais parce
qu'en plus je sais jamais si c'est des
clowns blancs qu'on a maquillé ou s'ils
sont vraiment des clowns blancs et vous
croyez le bien des messes cloud long oui
ça veut dire genre yahia l'obstétricien
oui je laisse et à croûte blanc et le
gris nez avec cannes et en os tout ça le
petit directeur les jours de van a
passés en jaune en quoi les chaussures
ont du mal à passer à la phase avait
[Rires]
alors raconté pas donc vous avez peur
déclare me terrifie
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
d'abord il va pas revenir alors ils
bossent ici comme c'est ma terreur c'est
ma nature mais je suis je peux voir quoi
en plus ça a l'air d'être un vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]